to make the Cheesecake layer they begin
with cream cheese they mix for three or
four minutes to soften it then blend in
sugar and salt next they add sour cream
to make the cheesecake creamier and
fluffier the last ingredients are whole
eggs blended with vanilla extract to
make the chocolate truffle cake base
they combine water sugar corn syrup and
cream of tartar while heating those
ingredients to a boil they soften butter
in a mixer then add melted semi-sweet
chocolate which contains vanilla extract
then they add the boiled ingredients
then coffee syrup
then blended whole eggs
the depositor is set up to squirt
exactly 28 ounces of the thick chocolate
truffle cake batter into each pan
this batter is much lighter than the
dense chocolate truffle cake batter
so rather than blend the two batters
form separate layers using the squeeze
bottle they drizzle on some extra
chocolate truffle cake batter
and drag a knife back and forth creating
what's known in pastry-making as a
Napoleon style design the long baking
time at a relatively low temperature
ensures the heat penetrates the dense
truffle batter gradually otherwise the
outside of the cake would burn before
the inside is fully baked the cakes cool
at room temperature then go into a
freezer overnight the next day workers
easily pop the rock-solid cakes from the
pans
thanks to that silicone liner they place
the cake on a cardboard circle then with
a pastry bag garnish the edge with fudge
ganache the ganache is made of heavy
cream corn syrup and the same melted
chocolate they put in the truffle cake
batter they place the finished chocolate
marble truffle cake into an automatic
cake slicer the turntable rotates after
each strike of the blade until the
machine is cut the cake into 12 slices
and separated them with paper dividers
they wrap the cake in a cardboard band
printed with a brand name
then they put the dessert through a
machine which encases the cake in
plastic film that applies heat to shrink
the film taut